the jurogan experience
and what is going on with eating so if
you have
one meal and say this meal comprises uh
you know 2 000 calories or whatever and
you have this meal at 6 p.m and you fast
for 24 hours until you eat again at 6 pm
if you have this one meal a day why is
it better to do that
than to have say you know smaller meals
of like 500 calories multiple times per
day
little snacks well because going back
six million years back you know we're in
the trees and then in the savannah
our bodies were designed well or evolved
to
respond to adversity and we've removed
that from our lives
because it feels good but we need
adversity to be resilient
and to fight disease so what i'm saying
is
that period of hunger and it's not even
hungry these days i don't even
feel it i feel great if if i don't eat
and it takes a few weeks so anyone wants
to start
make give it some time give it a couple
weeks but what's happening in the body
is
you're turning on these adversity
hormesis response genes we call them
longevity genes
and they make the body fight aging and
diseases
and so by by eating through the day the
traditional oh you gotta have breakfast
best meal of the day blah blah
first of all it's not true that you need
to be full or fed
to think clearly it's it's very clear
that people who are fasting
have as good if not better mental
acuity okay that's one so i think that
that needs to be throughout the window
kids
are different we're not saying that kids
are talking about adults and we're not
talking about malnutrition or starvation
too let's be clear
but we are talking about lengthening
that window
of not eating so if you always are
satiated fed your body says hey
i've just killed an you know a mammoth
no problem don't need to worry about
survival
i'm just going to go forth and multiply
and screw my long-term survival
so this is all about long-term survival
by making the body freak out
that there's tough times and that's
running away like running away from a
cat like the savannah and being hungry
or
you know there's molecular reasons that
all this works but you know trust me
that the data is very clear that this is
the way to go if you want to be healthy
in your 80s and 90s
well it it actually does make sense when
you put in that way that
your body when you're fed relaxes and so
if you're just doing that
all day long and i know for a fact that
when
i am um not fed and i go
and do things whether it's perform one
of the things that i've been doing
um is i don't eat
before shows like i take many uh many
hours before a comedy show and i used to
just like eat whenever
i just see and and then i would do shows
and i would have a meal like an hour
before the show and
i really trying to wake up i'm really
trying to come on come on come on
but i've now recognized actually i saw a
video where kat williams was talking
about this
do you know kat williams hilarious
comedian uh
i do know well you're slipping if you
don't uh he's
he's hilarious when he was doing this
interview and he's saying they were
what's your process before a show and
one of the things is i don't eat i make
sure i don't eat
and i was like that's wise that's really
smart and i'm like
i needed to hear that even though i kind
of knew it but i never written it down
i never like associated it absolutely
but now i have
like now i do not eat before shows i
won't do it unless i know i have three
hours
so what what's your average day look
like it depends entirely
on whether or not i'm doing podcasts if
i'm doing podcasts generally
i'm up early i get my workouts in i
usually have something to eat after the
workout so i'm talking about like i eat
around 11
11 a.m that's my first meal of the day
and then i go and do my stuff
and i generally feel like my workouts
are so strenuous that i need
some sort of nutrition afterwards some
sort of uh
fruit to pump the mussels back up and
give them some sugar
and some protein so usually i'm eating
meat and maybe like an apple or
something like that that's like a normal
meal for me
and then i don't eat again until
nighttime great and you're not snacking
no yeah maybe sometimes after our
podcast i'll have like
we have these uh on it warrior bars that
are just buffalo meat and
some cranberries and stuff i like those
i'll eat one of those
good well at least you're going till 11.
you got that sleep yeah so you're
probably not eating late
yeah it's just the str strenuous
activity
me like my workouts are very hard so
after them i feel like i need something
you know i just i don't like that
feeling of like a brutal workout and
then being starving for four or five
hours
because then it becomes a distraction so
i i listen to my body
but if i don't work out i don't eat
until dinner
like say a day like today i didn't work
out today so i woke up
hung out with the dog had some coffee
sat out you know
like just got went over some emails did
some [ __ ] just a relaxed morning
and then rolled into here no food
i won't eat until we're going to dinner
tonight right until then yeah with likes
that's gonna be fun and john donahue
yeah of course looking forward to
meeting yes
uh yeah so you're doing the right things
uh certainly better than most people
but what i'm trying to build make are
molecules that mimic
fasting as well so if you cannot fast
like i do
then you can just take a pill and what
we've shown in in mice at least
is that if you give them this molecule
that i'm taking nmn
nicotinamide mononucleotide which as i
mentioned
um speeds up metabolisms all that stuff
those mice could run
50 further these old mice we gave it to
them for three weeks
put them back on a treadmill and those
that had the anime in their water
around 50 for they had better blood flow
better oxygenation better
energy and that is literally exercising
a pill
that's crazy so we're in late stage
human clinical trials now
when do you think it's going to be
released to the public well it depends
on what the fda does and if it was
mobile
[ __ ] oh don't get me in trouble
i love the fda um fair enough they
protect us
yes but yeah we're going through the
procedure that has been around since as
i mentioned early 20th century
but we've done hundreds of people now
um certainly dozens over the last few
years
and we know at least that this molecule
is apparently safe
and raises the levels of the molecule we
want to build up the molecules called
nad
do you want me to talk a little bit yes
please so nad is what might
those mitochondria little uh mike and i
little uh
energy producing things use to
make energy so you need there are two
molecules in the body that are really
great you need both for life
and without them as i said you're dead
atp is the energy and nad
makes that and as we get older the
levels of nad go down our body makes
less and actually also degrades it more
you have
so i if you take my skin or in the study
that they took people's skin when you're
50
you've got half the levels of this nad
that you did then you did when you were
20.
which is scary because this is this
molecules required for life without it
we're dead
in 30 seconds so what we're doing with
our clinical trials is giving a
precursor a smaller version of this that
the body will turn into nad
and bring those levels back up from
where they are when you're old
to where you are when you're young and
we see at least in animals and hopefully
in people that it revs up
their metabolism and makes them fight
aging and disease
like we do when we're young i mean
there's a reason we don't get
a lot of heart disease when we're young
or alzheimer's because our bodies fight
against disease as we get older and
especially if we sit around or smoke
and don't exercise our bodies just give
up catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for
free only on spotify watch back catalog
jre videos on spotify including clips
seamlessly switch between video and
audio experience
on spotify you can listen to the jre in
the background by using other apps and
can download episodes to save on data
cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience